hi
i'm alan i'm from mit and today i'll be
talking about distributed load balancing
a new framework and improved guarantees
this is joint work with sarah and
marchesa from google research and
binghui from colombia
so let's begin with the problem setup so
in the problem there is a set of sources
s and a set of workers w and they are
connected via a bipartite graph so here
the sources are s1 s2 s3 and the workers
are w1 w2 and w3
now each source has one unit of load and
we must
distribute the load on each source among
the neighboring workers
so for each source we can split its one
unit of load arbitrarily among its
neighbors
now once all of the load has been
allocated we can compute the total load
on each worker
as the sum of the loads over all the
incident edges
so for instance in the graph zone the
total loads are one-half
two and one-half respectively
now the objective in our problem is to
balance the total loads on the workers
as much as possible
and the way we capture this balance and
subjective is via a
convex objective function so there are a
few technical details such as requiring
the
objective function is symmetric and
somewhat well behaved
however we will not go into those here
and almost any natural objective
function will fall under our framework
so to give a few examples we might
consider for instance the maximum load
objective
where we are trying to minimize the
maximum load on any worker
or even we may consider an l2 objective
where we are trying to
minimize the sum of the squared loads
and finally we may consider an lp
objective
now the final constraint is we want a
distributed algorithm
that runs in a small number of rounds
and we're working in the
standard congest model where each round
the notes may communicate
a poly logarithmic number of bits of
information with each of their neighbors
now the problem is primarily motivated
by web server and search engine
applications
so in these applications the sources
correspond to query sources such as
say users querying a web page and the
workers correspond to
data centers so there may be millions of
sources and millions of data centers
which is why we're primarily interested
in distributed algorithms that converge
in a small number of rams
and one of the main innovations in our
work is we're able to deal with general
context objective functions
and this is a much more diverse class
and is much more realistic
than say just the maximum load objective
or only other linear objectives
so now i'll talk about a few lines of
related work the first line of related
work is
in diffusion type load balancing so
this is in a model that is closely
related to ours except where the workers
may
communicate directly with each other and
split tasks among
split load amongst themselves however
existing algorithms for diffusive type
load balancing require a polynomial
number of rounds
and these algorithms can easily be
translated to our setting however
even in our setting they also require a
polynomial number of rounds
so here polynomial means polynomial in
the size of the graph
another line of related work is in
distributed matching algorithms or more
generally
distributed mixed packing and covering
lp solvers
so matching or yeah so the problem of
matching corresponds to
a linear objective function and so for
linear objective functions there are
algorithms that work in a
poly logarithmic number of rounds
however
these algorithms cannot be directly
applied to our setting as convex
objectives are actually
quite fundamentally different from
linear objectives to
maybe give some intuition for why this
is the case for a linear objective
the optimum always occurs at a vertex of
the feasibility polytope
however for a convex objective the
optimum may occur in the interior of the
feasibility polytope
so there's actually a lot of work to do
to
get a poly logarithmic
round convergence algorithm for general
convex objectives
so now let's talk about our results so
as alluded to
we give an algorithm that converges in a
poly logarithmic number of rounds
so our algorithm computes a one plus
epsilon approximation to the optimal
solution
and log n log squared d over epsilon
cubed rounds where n is the number of
nodes and d is the maximum degree
so this is for general convex objective
functions
now for the maximum load objective
we have a improved algorithm that
converges in log n log d over epsilon
squared rounds
and we'll note that this is actually
faster than a direct application of a
parallel mixed positive lp solver
by a log n over epsilon factor
so next i'll talk a bit about the key
technical
ideas behind our result so the first
main thing to understand is why previous
load balancing algorithms get stuck with
this polynomial dependence
on the size of the graph so previous
load balancing algorithms all rely on a
paradigm that is
they linearly shift traffic from higher
loaded workers to lower loaded workers
so what that looks like in our setting
is so let's consider
for instance we have some sources and
two workers with loads l1 and l2
now the source s2 is connected to both
of these workers
and so let's say l1 is much bigger than
l2
so then in one round what these
algorithms do is the shift delta times
l1 minus l2 load from edge a to hb
and so the parameter delta here is
basically some sort of step size
now the reason why these algorithms get
stuck with this polynomial dependence on
the size of the graph
is that
the step size delta must be set must
be set to be sufficiently small as
otherwise
we cannot guarantee convergence and the
algorithm may oscillate
so delta has to be as small as say one
over the maximum degree
and thus the convergence rate will be
something that is polynomial in the
maximum degree
so to understand this a little bit
better let's even go through
a concrete example so consider a graph
that isn't matching
but there's one additional worker
connected to all the sources
so for instance in the following graph
there's s1 s2 s4 s5
and then l1 l2 l4 l5 and there's some
matching and then there's an additional
worker
all three that is connected to all of
the sources
so initially let's assume that all of
the load is distributed according to the
matching
so the red edges contain one unit of
load and the black edges contain no
zero units of load so of course this
allocation is sub-optimal
and in order to make it optimal you must
send one-fifth unit of load
from each of the sources s1 s2 s4 s5
onto the
middle worker l3 so what this really
means is that
the step size has to be as small as one
over the degree of the middle node
in order for us to get to the optimum
solution
so of course in this trivial example
in this example we can have some trivial
algorithms that beat this
simple example however if we try a
little bit harder we can also construct
examples
where it is necessary to shift load much
more aggressively than whatever the
degree
and so uh so given that this is a very
natural thing to try
we tried to get around these hard
examples with this sort of linear
traffic shifting algorithm
and it does appear to be difficult to
deal with all these different possible
hard cases
so what we do for our algorithm is we
actually adopt a completely different
approach so the first insight
is the following so if we actually know
the target loads in the optimal solution
then computing a way to distribute the
loads that satisfies those targets
is just a matching problem and as
mentioned before
matching can be solved in a poly
logarithmic number of rounds
so this naturally leads us to an
algorithm of the following form
so uh let's assume first that we're
working with the maximum load objective
function so we only care about
minimizing the maximum load
so we can maintain target capacities for
each worker
and initialize these targets to be very
large now we
iteratively test feasibility and then if
it's feasible we decrease the target
capacities
until we reach a configuration that is
barely feasible
and now this will actually work for the
maximum load objective function
however for general convex objective
functions will require a much more
refined approach
because we cannot decrease all of the
target capacity simultaneously
so what is our approach for general
context objectives
our approach for general convex
objectives is inspired by the previous
approach with some additional twists
so we'll initialize target capacities
for each worker
so say we'll initialize them to all be
equal to the maximum degree
so of course this will ensure that
the initial targets are feasible
now we'll test feasibility using a
proportional
allocation algorithm based on the work
of agrawal at
all so we'll use this algorithm in a
very
box manner and i'll explain and
uh the rest of this slide and the next
few slides will really focus on
understanding
this proportional allocation algorithm
so what this proportional allocation
algorithm will do
is when it attempts to test feasibility
it will give us a solution that is
close to feasible now once we see the
output of this proportional allocation
algorithm
will freeze the target capacities of
some workers that
will call tight so what these tight
workers are
is workers whose capacities cannot be
improved upon
in any feasible solution so
due to the properties of this algorithm
we'll actually be able to construct a
certificate
that shows that in any feasible solution
we cannot significantly decrease the
loads on we cannot significantly
improve on these tight workers
so once we find the tight workers we can
decrease the target capacities
for the workers that are not tight so
we'll decrease the target capacities for
the unfrozen workers
and then we'll iterate steps two and
three so testing feasibility
and then decreasing target capacities
for a poly logarithmic number of rounds
until we reach conversions
so now the key cog in our algorithm is
this proportional allocation
so let's try to understand this better
now so
let's label the workers 1 through w and
we'll initialize
let's let's say we have some target
capacity c1 through cw
now proportional allocation works as
follows so we
initialize weights for some of the
workers say a1 through aw
and now we allocate all this loads on
the sources proportional to the weights
on the workers
so for instance in the following graph
we have a source
s and then the workers one two and three
with weights
one two and three respectively now
we'll allocate the load on s according
proportional to the weights
so we'll have one sixth load joint to
worker one
one third load going to worker two and
one half load going to worker three
now we'll proportionally allocate the
load
on all of the sources now once all of
the load is allocated
for each worker we can compute a total
load
if the total load is below the target
capacity then we
increase its then we
increase its weight by a one plus
epsilon factor and
otherwise we decrease its weight by a
one plus epsilon factor
and then we'll simply repeat steps two
and three for a poly logarithmic number
of rounds
and so really the reason we can get away
with poly logarithmic here is
because we're now using a multiplicative
weights type of approach
now uh let's to
give a brief summary of the analysis of
this proportional allocation algorithm
so again i've included the
uh i've included a summary of the
algorithm as a reminder
so now here are a few key observations
and
the analysis of proportional allocation
so the first is that if the load is
within
a one plus epsilon factor of the target
capacity then it will
always remain that way
and so the reason for this is the
following so
because of the way we're updating the
waste we can ensure that
the loads are always moving towards the
target capacities
so if the load is too high then it's
moving down if the load is too low then
it's moving up
and so now once we're within a one plus
epsilon factor since we're
always moving in the right direction and
we're never stepping
like all the steps are of size at most
the factor of one plus epsilon
we'll always remain close to the target
capacity
now also since we're always moving in
the right direction
if we know that at some point the load
is much bigger than the target capacity
then this means that the weight has been
decreased at every previous step
and so similarly if the load is much
less than the target capacity then the
weight has been
increased at every previous step
so what this means is that there is a
poly
in n so polynomial in n and polynomial
and n and epsilon
multiplicative gap between the weights
of significantly underloaded
and significantly overloaded workers
so this is really the key observation
about the behavior of the algorithm
so again uh i've included this key
observation
for as a reminder and now what does this
really mean so if we have a source s
that's connected to two workers
where so to w1 is significantly
underloaded and w2 is significantly
overloaded
then what happens so actually what this
means is the amount of load being sent
to w2 is negligible
because there's a poly and n
multiplicative gap between the two
weights
so basically what this means is that
we can cut the edge between s and the
second worker
so again there's a few more details to
work through
but what this essentially allows us to
do is we can actually construct a cut
certifying that
if we have some significantly overloaded
workers that we cannot
significantly improve on them
so now uh again i'll give a brief
summary
of how we put everything together in our
full algorithm
so again i'll omit a lot of details
so our full algorithm and our full
algorithm
will run proportional allocation with a
given set of target capacities
and now if after running proportional
allocation
the load is more than one plus 10
epsilon times the target capacity
then we'll freeze the target capacity
and then we'll decrease the target
capacities on unfrozen workers by a
factor of one plus epsilon
so what the oneplus 10 epsilon really is
for
is that if the load is more than one
plus 10 epsilon times the target
capacity
then the basically the it's
significantly overloaded and this will
let us
construct a certificate from
the proportional allocation algorithm
so uh really a quick summary of
how the analysis works so since we start
from a
feasible allocation where we can ensure
that no worker is ever more than
one plus 11 epsilon overloaded
and then to certify optimality what we
do is
we construct a hierarchy of certificates
so we show that
basically each time we run proportion
allocation
and then freeze some set of workers that
our solution is
essentially optimal when restricted to
the set of frozen workers at the end of
each round
so this will give us a hierarchy of
certificates
so actually this what i wrote on the
side is not
quite it doesn't quite work and well
what we actually do in our paper is
something slightly different so
or is a slight modification so we'll
actually
our certificates will be for a superset
of the set of frozen workers
at the end of each round but
anyways so here's a quick summary of how
how our full algorithm works
and now finally once we have this
hierarchy of certificates
the way we bound the objective value is
we
use some standard majorization
inequalities
so to summarize in this paper we give a
distributed algorithm for load balancing
that computes a
nearly optimal solution in a poly
logarithmic number of rounds
whereas previous algorithms for load
balancing required a polynomial number
of rounds
and our algorithm works for general
convex objective functions
and our we introduce a
completely different approach that gets
around some barriers for previous load
balancing
algorithms so our new approach in our
new approach we
iteratively use matching algorithms
which do conversion of poly logarithmic
number of rounds
we use these matching algorithms to test
feasibility
then update target capacities according
to the output of our matching algorithms
and then iterating this we converge to
an optimal solution so that's all for
the talk and thanks for listening